hello and welcome to this video playing
ak
61 with white
lost two times already against this
person
no particular
no particular memory
of the games so going for
my entire king's indian line from the
keep it simple d4 book
bookend opening course on chessable
i still tend to say book even though
it's an opening course on chessable
okay so c form
i took a moment because d5 i was not
quite sure
d5 knight bd2 a3 is a bit
looks a bit annoying okay i'm stopping
that
okay i can go with c5 here or
taking is also a thing
yeah i go c5 the a4 pawn is
um still a liability for black so
i think um
i'm quite quite okay here knight c3
okay and probably knight to f6
for knight e4 no this one
i can take this and try to prove that
the c pawn is weak on the file i'm not
sure
95 however also looks like a small
advantage
just due to the space
maybe not after this one yeah that's
that's true
f4 that's knight f6 that's not a good
move
okay knight d3
e5 probably
maybe e4 e4
it takes a couple of times and then i
take d5
yeah a little bit faster wouldn't help
wouldn't help wouldn't hurt
an interesting idea is knight takes e5
knight xc5 d takes e5 d4 is interesting
i guess it goes e6 okay
now now i can take and go e5 just
yeah go for this huge space advantage
this is a solution that i like
it gives some
this a pretty one-sided i think
one side a touch
hard to imagine that white could ever be
worse here with this huge space
okay i can t both captures um
make some sense actually
d takes d takes i'm concerned a little
bit about
node g5 and i had to g5 i have queen g4
that cannot be good
yeah then i have to take with the deep
one
okay quinju form or
queen h5 something like that
he will go king h8 this is um absolutely
sure
that's uh i'm reasonably sure about that
but why move the queen actually that
makes no sense
i have to get the rook on the g file
ultimately so king h1
it's just stronger
okay this was one reason for queen g4
why
why i thought it would be interesting
[Music]
okay go there he can make um
yeah he can play for
he can play for an exchange sack now
bishop g6 coming
yeah that's annoying
and i really i cannot really do much
about this
this is much easier now for black to
play and i have no time on the clock
i will lose this game again against this
person
it's just an awful position in a
practical game
yeah cannot cannot play this impossible
bishop h6 and whatever just easy for
black
i don't think he saw that but it might
still work bishop takes f5 and
h6
a blundered which it doesn't matter
position is still awful
okay i have 11 seconds so it's not like
i'm immediately losing on time so
i can think about this for
a moment at least
it should be for
now this is bad really that was bad
it's not a position that i should ever
lose
because i'm just completely one-sidedly
better of course
like here this is just hugely better for
white
and um yeah i don't know
so tm i don't know i mean can't think
with the f
pawn that's the kind of thing that you
would just press forever and
nothing will ever happen that is the
advantage of this move
is probably a draw though because of the
symmetrical pawn structure and
i mean e6 is just a terribly bad move
honestly
that should never be played black is
fine probably with many lines the line
that i felt was most interesting
was this which which looks really
interesting actually
but okay you played e6 which is you know
double question mark is strong but it's
not
totally totally wrong
i even had wins at the very end here
i don't even want to see that i already
feel like i want to
whatever this it's just awful to lose
this kind of game
so yeah king h1 i was actually
reasonably happy
about but
yeah this was the first instinct that i
had
simply trying to stop this bishop
maneuver
because i'm only six it's not clear that
i'm totally stopping it but
i had to king h1 take take bishop eight
yeah and now i mean that is a that's a
very standard type of sacrifice
and it's okay that's okay i'm also not
sure that the computer is getting the
eval right here
maybe i should never take because this
i'm absolutely sure it's not better for
white i mean that is
just not happening the bishop coming to
e4 is just so
strong in a practical game where i have
like
seconds this is unplayable actually
strange that he
didn't kill me maybe you thought
everything wins that
that is a
that that is a feasible thing to to
think
so yeah he totally blunted f5 but it is
still good for black
is the thing so
ph4 rookie 3 was winning okay i'm
trapping the queen
okay
and here again i'm trapping the queen i
didn't see that at all
yeah okay
then there were i made a couple of more
blunders with no time but
yeah you're just out there in the open
against all those pieces
hmm yeah that's a really annoying loss
i had one minute so i should play
d-takes it must be the better move in
comparison
i knew that this is going to be a
difficult more difficult to play
but you cannot always make the safe
choice this is
something where you will never lose i
play queen e2 bishop d2
and try to slowly press on the king side
and you can
um try around with ever risking anything
without ever risking anything but black
is just probably trading down the house
and nothing ever happens so
yeah it was a bad one thanks for
watching